بالنسبة للسويد وفنلندا
ليس لدينا مثل هذه المشاكل مع السويد و
فنلندا التي توجد للأسف
أوكرانيا ليس لدينا أي إقليم
الأسئلة لا الخلافات ليس لدينا أي شيء
قد نكون قلقين من حيث
عضوية
فنلندا أو السويد في الناتو ، حسنًا ، أريد
إيم من فضلك فقط يجب أن تكون واضحة و
تخيل بوضوح ما كانوا عليه
لم تكن هناك تهديدات
[موسيقى]
الآن
إذا كان هناك جيش
لدينا البنية التحتية للوحدات
سنجيب المرآة و
تشكل نفس التهديد على الإقليم
من أين التهديدات التي نواجهها؟
من الواضح أنهم لا يفهمون ذلك
كان كل شيء على ما يرام معنا ، ولكن الآن
بعض التوتر واضح
بالتأكيد مثل هذا مستحيل
أكرر إذا كان سيتم إنشاؤه بواسطتنا
التهديدات
[موسيقى]
أوه على
في
[موسيقى]
نعم الوصول والتمويل سوف تبدأ
توماس كالمانوفيتش ولذا فهي فارغة
تجربة وستكون هناك حلقة اختبار
يتظاهر بممارسة الجنس ويشمل ذلك أنهم يمارسون الجنس
عليهم فارغة على هذه المجموعة من النبيذ من النوافذ هم
طويلة دوموس هذه الدراجة خاصة
تزامنت جولة إبليس اللعين مع الفحم الذي تريده
تنصح التشعبات المالية بالوقوف على الستر
أقل تغيير ظهر Vovka mda-a
رسم الماضي حزين
ترى ساحة الأفكار والشبابيك فارغة جديدة
مقالات تشاك إند أندو من هذه الشركة
ينشر نتحدث فقط انظر صدى
أفسح المجال للمفهوم وعرضه عندما
زحف الزحف والزحف أهمية
في المنصة 5 من الأفضل قبل ذلك وبعده
تم تحديد تاريخ ألفونسو الخاص بك
ثابتة